i need this in my life hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at lifestyle youtuber michelle choi but
first let me tell you what my sponsor
cook unity as a food blogger and
cookbook author i spend a lot of time in
the kitchen but i'm also a really busy
mom of two and a business owner so there
are a lot of days when i just can't
sometimes i don't have the inspiration
sometimes i don't have the time
sometimes i don't have the ingredients
and sometimes i just don't have the
drive so whenever we're down south in
the states we always stock up on some of
the creative signature meals from coke
unity so cook unity has over 50 talented
chefs from some of the best restaurants
in the country working out of regional
micro kitchens instead of massive
production facilities so you feel like
you're getting a restaurant meal at home
basically you just let them know what
you like and what you don't like and you
pick a flexible meal plan so you can get
as few as four or as many as 16 meals
per week then you can select from
hundreds of meals that align with your
preferences and dietary restrictions
including keto vegan paleo gluten free
low sodium and more and they use all
really high quality chef driven
ingredients so the meals are delivered
fresh not frozen in compostable
recyclable or reusable packaging along
with expiration dates heating
instructions and nutrition stats and
then a few days before your delivery you
get a text to make your selections for
the next week it really feels like one
big thing off my plate that i can't
screw up everything i've tried is
amazing and the menu rotates constantly
with a wide range of different cultural
flavors and preparations so it really
helps to fill the gaps with inspiring
fun meals for those nights when things
get really hectic so if you want to try
cook unity out yourself go to
cookunity.com
abby or click the link in the
description and use my code abby50 to
get 50 off of your first order of meals
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on tik tok and instagram at abby's
kitchen so michelle has been doing some
serious numbers with her living alone
diaries on youtube and in march she
shared what she eats in a day alone and
i feel like this is content that so many
people need so let's dive in
so echinacea has been long touted as a
natural remedy to boost your immune
system and fight the common cold
honestly i grew up thinking that this
was just gospel and it was fact because
that's what my mom gave me whenever i
was sick and there actually has been a
lot of research on this none of which is
super overwhelmingly conclusive so a
2006 review found that it could not
prevent a cold but it could possibly
lessen its length or severity then a
2014 review suggested it might have
small preventative benefits and a 2015
review found that it could possibly
reduce the risk of actually getting a
cold by up to 35
by increasing the response of natural
killer cells so this is not necessarily
on par with medicine but i would say
it's probably worth a shot if you're
prone to catching the common cold
probably should have tried that before
getting into bed with my snotty always
sick toddlers hence the rasp my brain is
on fire i'm dying but anyways if that is
in fact michelle's intended use she
actually didn't say i would consider a
few other supplements as well so we do
have research to support vitamin d for
lowering the risk of respiratory
infections and that vitamin c zinc and
elderberry extract may also help to
shorten the duration of colds but if she
just likes the flavor or this is part of
her morning ritual echinacea is
generally considered safe for most
people and it may also have some immune
supporting benefits as we've discussed
[Music]
i need this in my life i mean when you
think about it like a burger is just
some sort of protein like packed between
carbs with some kind of sauce on it
it's a hamburger made out of meat on a
bun with nothing add ketchup if you want
i couldn't care less so we're just
replacing the usual bun with like a
compact patty of umami infused rice i
love the umami flavor
stop being so pretentious kyle and i
also love that she made it more
breakfast themed with adding the egg in
there for some extra protein to
complement the protein in the tuna as
well all i would do is maybe suggest
amping up the fiber a bit here since we
are only looking at less than two grams
in this meal so add respect to like not
mess with the nostalgic favorite meal
itself we don't necessarily have to add
anything to the burger if that's not how
we like it but i would just pair it with
a piece or two of fruit on the side
getting your produce in in the morning
is a great way to start the day this
reminds me of my college days
i actually loved eating food like this
where it was just packaged very compact
and you can eat it really fast and easy
on the go uh this is more than a few
steps up from what i ate when i was in
university and i was like a food and
nutrition major so it was kind of
expected that we knew how to cook but i
will just say that while there is a bit
of assembly involved in a meal like this
it is one of those meals that you can't
really mess up and i would say like all
the ingredients are super cheap and
cheerful and we love to see that rice
canned tuna eggs miso soup are all great
inexpensive staples for anyone to have
on hand
and there we have it
love that the girl is not afraid to
serve herself seconds or thirds you
honor that hunger girl you guys know i'm
a big fan of that you can also just tell
how much satisfaction she's deriving
from her meals just by all the little
mmms and like the food dance you know we
all do that little
wiggle when a meal is just like hitting
right
[Music]
as for the meal itself we are getting
another double dose of protein from the
tofu and the pork more gut friendly
probiotics from the kimchi as well as a
bit of veg and fiber action from the
onions and bell pepper but considering
we did have a lower fiber breakfast i
would use this opportunity to just sneak
in a little more fiber and the best way
to do this is actually not to swap the
white rice for brown rice as so many
kind of healthy hack listicles may
suggest honestly when you compare white
and brown rice brown rice only has like
a gram more fiber per hundred gram
serving nothing to write home about not
to mention white rice actually has less
arsenic than brown rice so if rice is a
main fixture of your diet it is
something to consider you can also
reduce the arsenic risk by washing your
rice really well cooking it in plenty of
water using an aromatic rice like
basmati or jasmine and most importantly
focusing on diet diversity when you can
so if this were my meal i would just
focus on maybe adding more fresh or
frozen vegetables in here so that could
be a few handfuls of chopped spinach
broccoli or bok choy or really any
leftover veg that she might have already
kicking around in her fridge when i was
younger i used to eat hot cheetos with
rice and ham i would get a piece of ham
i'll put rice and lay a piece of hot
cheeto wrap it and eat it
and actually still taste really good
you guys watching this i probably
thinking i am crazy she thinks this is
crazy but to be honest i don't know how
this could possibly taste bad you could
put hot cheetos on just about anything
and i will crush them plus she's
actually adding some fat and protein
from the ham in there to a carb rich
snack so to that i say it's hitting
those hunger crushing compounds hard we
love it
[Music]
and enjoy this while watching my crew
so i'm glad to see that we're getting a
solid amount of fiber and potassium from
the fruit and the greens in this
smoothie and because there has been a
fair bit of sodium in this day from the
soup mix and the sauces and the cheetos
the potassium from the fruit and veggies
will be a great choice sodium and
potassium have a bit of an inverse
relationship when it comes to a healthy
heart we used to harp on sodium alone as
being the cause of hypertension and
other cardiovascular risks but it now
seems that the sodium to potassium ratio
is actually a better indicator of risk
so research suggests we ideally want a
three to one ratio of potassium to
sodium in our diet which most north
americans find remarkably challenging to
achieve and it really is quite
challenging so this snack is packed with
produce and we're still getting one and
a half times more sodium than potassium
from the dumplings in the sauce
personally sodium isn't something that i
worry that much about for young healthy
individuals i mean a 2011 cochrane
review found that a reduced salt diet
didn't even seem to have a clinically
significant outcome for cardiovascular
morbidity or mortality but our daily
salt recommendations may have more
significance to certain populations as
some people are just more sensitive to
sodium's effects so if you've been told
you need to cut back focus on adding as
much colorful produce to meals and
snacks and choosing lower sodium sauces
or packaged foods wherever possible so
for example coconut aminos has 90
milligrams of sodium compared to 280 in
regular soy sauce and 190 milligrams in
the reduced sodium soy so experiment
with different brands if sodium is an
issue for you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i am so happy right now everything
turned out so good i could watch
michelle cook and um and ah over her
meal all day long this looks awesome i
love that we're taking some shortcuts
here with the pancake mix and the frozen
seafood and the salad greens and the
acorn jelly because i don't know i
looked up a recipe for that acorn jelly
and that is intense store-bought i can
do but we are getting lots of protein
from the seafood we got fiber in the
side salad as well as some fats from the
sesame oil and some seeds and i had
never heard of acorn jelly before but it
is apparently sodium free has a bit of
fiber and has only 40 calories per
serving so definitely something to check
out the next time i'm at the market yes
again this is a high sodium meal mainly
because the girl gets pretty generous on
the soy sauce on her greens i mean hey
if she likes it and it doesn't bother
her then i get the sense that she knows
her body's needs well some of us myself
included actually just need a little
extra salt but if you are sensitive and
you want to make a salad like this at
home you could swap out the soy for a
rice wine vinegar and then season with a
hint of salt or soy
it's brown sugar bubble milk tea cream
bar
i'm so so full right now but
there's always room for dessert brown
sugar bubble tea ice cream sounds fire
and i don't normally like bubble tea but
if it's brown sugar i'm there and while
michelle does comment on how full she
feels i think it's worth distinguishing
between the different types of hunger
all of which are valid reasons to eat so
of course we've got stomach hunger which
is the physical sensation of hunger
which is usually signaled by physical
cues like a grumbling stomach or our
stomach feeling physically full after a
meal then there is mouth hunger which
has more to do with the senses so it
could be a craving for a particular
aspect of food like sweet or crunchy or
salty so michelle's comment that she was
full but she could always find room for
dessert is an example of that mouth
hunger and we've all felt that need and
then there's heart hunger which is
usually tied to our emotions so we may
feel a desire to eat certain foods as a
way to self-soothe or cope with
different emotions which is independent
from our physical need for food or when
we were to have last eaten so while we
definitely want to hone in on those
internal hunger and fullness cues eating
is not black and white and there are so
many other factors at play that are
driving our food decisions every day
despite what diet culture will tell you
it's just as valid to eat because you
want something sweet than it is to eat
when your tummy is grumbling so consider
it best practice to not ignore these
hungers but to become aware of them
honor them and to collect data about
them judgment free so if capping off a
night with some ice cream feels
emotionally satisfying to michelle
despite feeling full then i say yes
enjoy that ice cream and move on with
all that said what are my overall
thoughts here well on this particular
day it does seem that michelle is
meeting her caloric needs as she's
definitely within the ballpark for her
general size and age and she also
doesn't seem to be restricting or
depriving herself of any of the foods
that she loves she calmly serves herself
a second helping without judgment when
she wanted it and she had dessert even
though she was full there were also no
diet culture qualifying statements to
justify her choices she just chooses
foods that she enjoy cooking and eating
i mean the audible mmms and oz at every
meal
truly speak for themselves i also love
that she embraces her cultural foods in
an easy and accessible way by leaning on
a few quick cooking hacks and some
frozen or prepackaged foods i know food
content isn't michelle's niche but i
would 100 t watch more food vlogs from
her and on that note that is all that i
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who or what
i should review next subscribe to the
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]